[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo comme chaque
vendredi nous faisons le point sur
l'actualité de la semaine dans le
département
au sommaire de cette édition les
résultats du baccalauréat dévoilé ce
vendredi 6 juillet ils étaient près de
dix neuf mille lycéens yvelinois à
passer l'examen cette année beaucoup
d'émotion notamment au lycée polyvalent
dumont d'urville à maurepas nous étions
sur place
reportage à suivre le conseil
départemental investis dans la
rénovation urbaine près de 700 millions
d'euros entre 2018 et 2022 4 une
première convention a été signée avec
grand paris seine et oise ce jeudi avec
la présence de jean louis borloo
entretient avec l'ancien ministre dans
cette édition
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
retour sur la présentation du dispositif
volontaire du tourisme en ile-de-france
et la matinée à l'estaca à propos des
jeux olympiques de 2024
avant de développer ses titres les pros
vise les prévisions sur la route ce
week-end pour les départs en vacances
bison futé voit rouge dans le sens des
départs pour la journée de samedi dans
les yvelines le secteur de la dce
devrait être saturé notamment à hauteur
du péage de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines la
circulation sera difficile entre 7h et
12h et un peu moins dense durant l'après
midi comme vous le voyez à l'image donc
une seule note un trafic saturé entre 7h
et 12h
concernant dimanche la journée est
classée verte par bison futé avec un pic
de saturation à saint-arnoult prévu
entre 10 heures et midi
pour plus d'informations sur vos
conditions de circulation rendez vous
sur le site bison tirer futé point
gouv.fr avant de partir en vacances
dernier jour de classe pour les écoliers
yvelinois à l'école élémentaire de la
vie du à elancourt jeux activités
ludiques et moment détente
au programme un jour particulier aussi
pour la directrice de l'établissement
anne marie crous elle prend sa retraite
après douze années passées dans l'école
élémentaire de lavilledieu à elancourt
entre joie d'être en vacances et
tristesse de quitter leur enseignante
écoutez la réaction de
ces élèves chez un petit peu triste en
même temps parce que quand même madame
cruise était une de mes meilleures
maîtresse que j'avais eue est à la fois
un petit peu joyeuse puisque c'est à peu
près les vacances je vais voir mes
papiers mais manu champêtre crise parce
que y'a quand même et les deux
maîtresses et cm1 qui vont partir madame
cruise à la retraite madame gauthier
dans une autre école donc vous ça veut
dire qu'on les reverra pas mais je suis
aussi contente parce que c'est les
vacances ce soir donc on va voir partir
leurs vacances et s'amuser oui je suis
très content des points les vacances
mais aussi un peu dégoûté pour madame
cruise parce que c'était une très bonne
maîtrise et tout le monde l'aimé et vous
retrouverez le reportage complet sur ce
sujet dans le journal le 7-8 journal le
lundi à 18 heures et on poursuit notre
page éducation avec les résultats du
baccalauréat ils sont tombés ce vendredi
matin au lycée polyvalent dumont
d'urville a à maurepas
l'émotion était présente pour les 500
élèves qui venaient découvrir leurs
notes
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
et nicolas kirillovitch devant le lycée
polyvalent dumont d'urville à maurepas
les élèves de terminale patiente pour
connaître les résultats du baccalauréat
et enfin les grilles s'ouvrent à 10
heures
[Applaudissements]
m
les 500 élèves découvrent le verdict au
total plus de 400 lycéens sont admis je
l'avais pas en fait ce n'était pas le
bon jury je suis contente j'ai des
valeurs peu stressé mais ça va je suis
content en place et l'importance et de
la voix après les mensonges
c'est mieux mais sans mention des
abattants dans la foule une dizaine de
parents est venu pour soutenir leurs
enfants ils ont eux aussi eu leur part
d'émotion on va quand celle d'avant et
puis est parti pour une nouvelle
aventure
une vingtaine d'élèves devront quant à
eux rester une année de plus au lycée
avant de penser à une nouvelle aventure
on reprendra 17 bénéfique c
on va vraiment bien travaillé pour
essayer d'avoir une mention d'autres au
contraire ont une nouvelle chance de se
reprendre ils sont 80 être admis à
l'épreuve du rattrapage
j'avais avis enfin vous rapport qui met
le bac mais pour cette prime ne m'aide
pas alors qu'elles étaient m ils
choisissent deux épreuves
donc il ya une stratégie à mettre en
place c'est la raison pour laquelle il
ya des enseignants des différents lycées
ils sont là pour qu'il fasse le bon
choix
le rattrapage sera organisée par
l'établissement sur deux jours lundi et
mardi prochains une dernière étape avant
de pouvoir profiter des vacances
estivales le département des yvelines a
signé sa première convention de son plan
d'abord ce dans le cadre de la
rénovation urbaine
ce jeudi 5 juillet à
chanteloup-les-vignes un engagement avec
la communauté urbaine grand paris seine
et oise
objectif permettre à huit communes
d'engager leurs opérations de rénovation
urbaine
une signature en présence de l'ancien
ministre délégué à la ville jean louis
borloo borloo pardon reportage 22
opérations de rénovation urbaine sur
huit communes de la vallée de seine pour
un montant total des travaux estimé à 66
millions d'euros l'objet de la première
convention signée entre les yvelines et
la communauté urbaine grand paris seine
et oise un engagement de plus de 22
millions d'euros pour le département
nous avons sélectionné les projets qui
peuvent démarrer tout de suite pour
recréer cette dynamique du changement
cette dynamique de l'espérance qui
disparaît de ces quartiers difficiles
dont je rappelle qu'ils représentent en
france comme à divine 10% de la
population ce qui est considérable parmi
ces projets la construction du pôle léo
lagrange aux mureaux une infrastructures
éducatives et sportives pour un
investissement total de 15 millions
d'euros dont 3,5 millions pris en charge
par le département à la fois c'est un
abondement financiers mais ce que je
trouve intéressant par rapport aux
départements
c'est le fait qu'ils anticipent et donc
ça nous permet éventuellement de
démarrer immédiatement sans que ne soit
nous ayons recours à l'emprunt et
l'intérêt que
département mais comme la communauté
urbaine comment ces financements c'est
qu'on va pouvoir démarrer les travaux
sans attendre quoi que ce soit donc
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on en est encore
recherchée parce que c'est 70% des
financements il ya 15 millions d'euros
il ya 10 millions de retrouver on a
trouvé six camps landru on a cherché à
ce qu'ils en ont mais aussi la région le
département souhaite consacrer 700
millions d'euros entre 2018 et 2022 4
pour la rénovation urbaine
il devrait signer une convention avec
saint quentin en yvelines et la
communauté d'agglomération des boucles
de seine en septembre prochain
l'ancien ministre délégué à la ville de
jean louis borloo a été invité par le
conseil départemental a participé à
cette signature en avril dernier il a
rendu un rapport sur les banlieues au
gouvernement et au président de la
république 19 proposition écartée par le
président de la république
emmanuel macron jean louis borloo
prévoyait notamment de réconcilier la
république avec ses banlieues écoutez
c'est 30e entretien réalisé ce jeudi sur
des images de patrick jacques de dixmude
jean louis borloo bonjour bonjour alors
nous sommes à la recherche d'un centre
culturel à chanteloup les vignes
c'est un espace culturel à proximité
d'un quartier prioritaire de politique
de la ville
est ce que c'est ça la réconciliation
entre la république et ses banlieues
pauvres surtout une réconciliation
humaine enfin réconciliation il faut en
tous les cas que chaque cas est partout
les mêmes chances tout est difficile
pour tout le monde mais parfois c'est un
peu plus difficile
et c'est ça qu'il faut régler amélioré
je trouve que à chantilly ou si on
regarde sur sur une quinzaine d'années
un travail spectaculaire dont se sentent
mais pas seulement il ya tout le centre
d'information jeunesse à ce très beau
bâtiment je peux comment il s'appelle
d'ailleurs il faut pas m'en vouloir mais
mais aussi à beaucoup de difficultés
encore bien entendu à les réseaux les
réseaux pour avoir un boulot
cet axe est la fois la qualification de
la formation bon mais mais c'est vital
pour notre pays non c'est tout simple
face à la tente des financements de
l'anru agence nationale de rénovation
urbaine le conseil départemental des
yvelines a décidé de débloquer 700
millions d'euros entre 2018 et 2020
4 qu'est ce que vous pensez de de ce
type d'initiative vraiment peut-être que
c'est l'une des premières en france
d'agresser largement la première enfin à
ceux à ce degré là de manière structurée
organisée avec autant de financement il
n'y a pas d'équivalent à ma connaissance
mais il ça m'étonne pas le département
des inuits présidée par l'ancien maire
demande connaît bien puisqu'elle
partie difficile à mantes qui est donc
être très impliqué depuis toujours vice
président et maire de chanteloup donc je
veux dire dans ce département qui
bailleurs pour être plutôt assez riche
assez bien doté il ya des endroits de
solidarité nécessaire très important et
c'est l' équilibre des événements
qu'elle joue comme ça alors ce jeudi 5
juillet vient d'être signé la convention
entre la communauté urbaine grand paris
seine et oise et le département des
yvelines c'est une enveloppe de 22
millions d'euros
justement c'est pour permettre la
rénovation urbaine 22 projets qui vont
être financés c'est une bonne chose est
ce que la solution vient des territoires
est ce que c'est une bonne chose va
évidemment elle vient tour des
territoires d'ailleurs on appelle l'
agence nationale de rénovation urbaine
stentor en fait c'était l'espèce de
bureau qui étaient là pour pour aider
les mères et les chalets c'était le seul
on aura lieu à plessala l'association
des amis des mets a déchiré plutôt qu'à
l'appeler agence spéciale de radio sur
ses pas à elle de décider c'est à elles
deux elles étaient là pour apporter les
quelques petites subventions nécessaires
voilà c'est ça sa mission dans le
rapport que vous avez rendu au
gouvernement en avril dernier
d'ailleurs qui a été écarté un par un
par le président la république et
d'ailleurs vous avez vu des explications
à ce sujet pourquoi le président n'a pas
pris en compte votre rapport je pense
qu'il le fera dans ce débat là dans ce
rapport notamment vous vouliez réformer
lagence nationale de rénovation urbaine
alors de quelle manière est pourquoi
tout simplement en mettant plus les élu
es et la population à la tête de sa
plutôt que là au fond sur un public de
bercy voilà je sais pas je pense que
c'est normal ce soit les régions les
villes les départements les hlm qui
dirige cette organisation
si vous étiez ministre de la ville
aujourd'hui qu'elle serait la première
première mesure que vous prendriez
les français ne sont pas très
accueillant les parisiens peu souriant
vous connaissez sûrement ses critiques
que peuvent nous adresser parfois les
touristes étrangers quand ils viennent
en france c'est pour contrer ces idées
reçues que la région ile de france a
lancé il y a deux ans les volontaires du
tourisme plusieurs centaines de jeunes
sont positionnés dans les endroits de la
région pour accueillir et aider les
visiteurs
la nouvelle saison des volontaires du
tourisme a été lancée en début de
semaine à paris nicolas kirillovitch et
patrick jacques de dixmude à paris ou
dans sa région il est impossible de les
rater quand ils se déploient les gilets
violer ce sont leurs surnoms il s'agit
en fait des volontaires du tourisme ils
sont 600 déployés cet été en ile de
france
leur mission guider et accueillir les
touristes étrangers à proximité des
lieux emblématiques de la région
ils sont là pour accueillir pour
souhaiter la bienvenue aux visiteurs
quels qu'ils soient franciliens
européens et mondiaux et de manière à ce
que les gens se sentent un peu moins
seul
depuis son lancement en décembre 2016
l'opération des volontaires du tourisme
a profité à plus de 1500 jeunes pour la
plupart des étudiants en tourisme qui
tirent profit de l'affluence des
vacances pour accumuler une précieuse
expérience professionnelle c'est un
secteur que j'ai tout j'ai aimé et ça
fait partie ont fait de magre de ma
formation puisque je suis en école de
commerce dont je pense que c'est une
belle opportunité représente la ville de
paris donc franchement c'est plutôt une
responsabilité
après une année 2010 est record pour le
secteur touristique les professionnels
espèrent un crue similaire cette année
pour amplifier son soutien la région
lancera également à la rentrée un pass
spécial où pourront s'accumuler offre
pour les transports et visites pour les
sites franciliens
nous voulons avoir le maximum de
partenaires sur se passe de façon à
éviter
devoir transporter sa carte bleue du
liquide sur soi
ce qui évidemment est source de
pickpockets d'insécurité donc impasse
très simple très rapide pour les
transports pour les musées l'an passé 48
millions de touristes ont visité l'île
de france l'année 2018 pourrait pâtir
des mouvements sociaux s'il se prolonge
tout l'été depuis plusieurs semaines en
france des boucheries sont attaqués par
des antispécistes des militants qui
considère l'homme et l'animal comme
égaux le phénomène a touché les yvelines
en début de semaine une boucherie de
jouy en josas a été attaquée vitrines
brisées et inscriptions du message je
cite stop aux spécisme nous avons reçu
jean raymond du bape résine au président
du syndicat de la boucherie et de la
charcuterie d'île de france ce jeudi
dans le journal ses cigares sont en fait
aidé des hommes et des femmes qui font
des métiers qu'ils n la revendication de
ces gens là ont l'art et serait mais on
doit pas s'attaquer à casser du matériel
et s'attaquer dès des humains comme ils
le font comme ils le font aujourd'hui
ce qu on a surtout peur c'est que ça
prenne des amplitudes de beaucoup plus
importante est close et chez nos
confrères des nouvelles de versailles
que ça finisse fonds drame ce genre de
situation c'est ce que j'espère c'est
que nous on veut pas la bagarre on veut
être au calme
on respecte ces gens là mais ce que j'ai
peur c'est que demain malheureusement un
de ces individus se fasse prendre part à
nos confrères aux collègues et que
malheureusement ça termine mais la
mesure est entrée en vigueur le dimanche
1er juillet les routes sans séparateur
central sont dorénavant limitée à 80
km/h au lieu de 90 depuis une semaine
les gendarmes de la sécurité routière
sensibilise les usagers rencontre au
bord des routes mais aussi dans les
lieux publics avec patrick jacques de
dixmude et mélanie poker et je ne
permets de vous donner un petit ailleurs
concernant le fameux 80 km heure cet
après-midi la padawan les deux perdent
deux points
les contrevenants sont sensibilisés les
gendarmes de la sécurité routière
contrôle sur la d 91 proche de la route
des 17 tournon je suis très agrément
surpris qu aujourd'hui la gendarmerie la
police fasse de la prévention et je
trouvais que ça avait disparu ces
derniers temps donc voilà c'est très
positif je pense et on est plus sensible
à partir du moment c'est de la
prévention à la répression de faire de
la prévention se trouve c'est une bonne
chose
par contre le 80 je suis vraiment pas
pour sept militaires sont mobilisés en
deux équipes ils contrôlent la vitesse
et les flux en vallée de chevreuse notre
mission c'est de faire appliquer le code
de la route aller à l'émission assez
simple mais il ya plein de façons de le
faire
dans le cas de cette mesure qui se fait
en période estivale à partir du dimanche
il est nécessaire d'accompagner cette
mesure donc des excès de vitesse qui
sont minimes qui sont mineurs si le
contrôle se passe de manière positive
avec la personne qui sont en infraction
on peut engager un dialogue et une
discussion pédagogie tôt mardi 4 juillet
la nouvelle limitation est en place la
sensibilisation continue même hangar il
faut laisser le temps de voir quels
seront les effets puisque l'on parle et
tout une guerre non ça sert à rien si on
regarde bien ce qui a fait la prévention
routière depuis le début elle a imposé
le port du casque on a dit que ça
servait à rien imposer la ceinture de
sécurité à l'avant on m'a dit ça servait
rien la ceinture de sécurité à l'arrière
on m'a dit que ça servait à rien chaque
fois ça a eu un impact quand même sur
nombre de points de contrôle indique que
c'est bon le dépistage à frictionner
correctement et là en fait la barre du
tout nous indique que c'est positif au
cannabis
c'est bien c'est au lieu de le voir tout
le temps faire des infractions il nous
explique un petit peu c'est je pense que
c'est c'est l'ordre des choses venaient
d instruction nous expliquer comment ça
fonctionne le gouvernement espère sauver
400 vies par an avec cette mesure dans
les yvelines 58 radars sont présents
deux sont concernés par la mesure du 80
km/heure d'ancizan paris recevra les
jeux olympiques d'été un rendez vous
également présent à saint quentin en
yvelines ou six épreuves sont
programmées
un événement qui se prépare dès
aujourd'hui ce mercredi 4 juillet les
pôles de compétitivité movéo systematic
paris-region organisé une matinée dédiée
au campus de l'estaca à montigny le
bretonneux
un rendez vous pour faire émerger des
projets et compétences pour le
territoire en vue de l'organisation de
la plus grande compétition sportive au
monde en 2024
reportage de grégory canale et carla
vigeant comment permettre un accès
facile aux épreuves alerté gérer une
situation de crise quelle diffusion de
l'information
autant de questions auxquelles il faudra
répondre d'ici les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques à paris en 2024 cette
matinée dédiée à l'estaca à montigny le
bretonneux avait pour but
de poser les jalons des projets en
matière de mobilité de sécurité
d'information dans la salle des
entreprises et acteurs des pôles de
compétitivité movéo et systematic
paris-region les jo 2000 24 seront une
opportunité extraordinaire et seront une
deadline aussi qui va pousser les
entreprises à se fédérer pour proposer
des solutions assez innovante des
technologies qui peuvent aider à la
sécurisation des sites à la facilitation
de la mobilité des transports pour les
visiteurs mais aussi pour les sportifs
fluidifier la circulation deux des 15 à
20 millions de visiteurs attendus à
l'occasion des chiots sur le territoire
en 2024 quatre sites à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueilleront
six épreuves des jo l'événement fera
venir au total 15 à 20 millions de
visiteurs à paris et sa banlieue
et dès aujourd'hui donc il faut
recueillir les projets innovants et
penser la logistique
on a un petit peu de temps mais pas tant
que ça c'est déjà dans six ans et
l'intérêt est de pouvoir faire émerger
des idées sur saint quentin en yvelines
d'entreprise de saint quentin en
yvelines en tout cas du plateau de
sacrée en général pour pouvoir répondre
à des besoins liés à l'organisation pour
optimiser l'organisation des jeux assure
saint quentin en yvelines le territoire
pourra déjà se tester en septembre avec
la ryder cup
soixante mille personnes par jour
devrait venir au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines lors des jo en 2024
est la seule épreuve de golf devrait
attirer 30000 spectateurs
quotidiennement dans l'agglomération les
vacances d'été c'est l'occasion pour les
communes de faire des travaux de voirie
trappe et maurepas vont procéder à des
réfections de routes
par conséquent des restrictions de
circulation ou des déviations seront
prévues pour les automobilistes
tour d'horizon de ces travaux avec toki
nirhy lanto
vacances est possible mal en patience
pour les automobilistes yvelinois
plusieurs travaux ont lieu cet été dans
le département le poncho l'air va être
doublée entre les communes de maurepas
et la verrière quant au pont cache un
attrape il va être réaménagée en vue de
couvrir la nationale 10 la voirie quant
à elle n'est pas en reste quelques
kilomètres d'enrobé seront posées dans
l'agglomération six communes sont
concernées elles encourent guyancourt
magny les hameaux
montigny le bretonneux trappe et voisins
le bretonneux
les travaux commencent dès le 9 juillet
outre les automobilistes les cyclistes
ne seront pas oubliés une nouvelle piste
cyclable s'ajoutera à celles existantes
à elancourt
même chose à magny les hameaux le long
de la départementale 195 tous ces
travaux devraient se terminer d'ici à la
rentrée de septembre et pour refermer ce
7,8 hebdo le début des vacances riment
avec pics d'activité pour les structures
touristiques du département au parc
zoologique de thoiry le personnel et les
pensionnaires s'apprête à accueillir les
visiteurs et avec la chaleur estivale
des animaux sont bichonnés pour
l'occasion un reportage de camille
lambert
il ne faut pas longtemps à tana et sa
famille pour reconnaître l'appel de
mathieu avec les fortes chaleurs les 18
maki catta du parc de thoiry endroit un
repas un peu spécial pas tous les jours
puisque il faut que ça reste
exceptionnel pour que ce soit un vrai
enrichissement
on va leur donner de temps à autre des
petits glaçons des petits glaçons
composé de fruits et de nectar de fruits
qu'on va préparer à l'avance pour pour
un petit peu les amuser pendant l'été et
les rafraîchir ouvert depuis l'an
dernier le lémur trek plonge le visiteur
dans l'enclos des lémuriens une
immersion sous certaines conditions
malgré leur accueil sympathique
interdiction de les toucher
si on les touche en fait ils risquent de
perdre leur identité c'est des animaux
qui communique beaucoup avec les odeurs
et en gros si dans une journée il ya 200
personnes qui leur font une petite
gratouille balle à la fin la journée le
lémurien il va avoir perdu son identité
olfactive est en fait il va stresser il
peut être si exclu du groupe
donc faut éviter cela à tout prix non
loin de madagascar direction l'australie
avec les nouveautés du parc cette année
un circuit parmi les kangourous et une
volière où cohabitent six espèces
d'oiseaux dont les loriquets arc en ciel
bien habitué aux visiteurs depuis avril
ils sont assez proches des visiteurs et
on fait avec eux chaque jour pendant
l'été deux nourrices âge va leur
proposer de nourrir les petits loriquets
donc c'est les petits gobelets avec du
nectar et les visiteurs peuvent
alors etc et qui leur montrent sur la
main une visite au plus proche des
animaux surtout des plus gourmands et
avant de refermer cette édition je vous
rappelle vos conditions de route pour ce
week end le samedi sera classé rouge par
bison futé dans les yvelines le secteur
de la dce devrait être saturé notamment
à hauteur du péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines avec une
circulation qui sera difficile entre 7h
et 12h
mais un peu moins dense durant l'après
midi dont conseil le plus tôt prendre la
route plus tôt le matin ou en fin
d'après midi
concernant dimanche la journée est
classée verte par bison futé avec un pic
de saturation à saint-arnoult prévu
entre 10 heures et midi
vous retrouvez les informations sur le
site internet bison tirer futé point
gouv.fr c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo
merci de nous avoir suivis si vous
souhaitez revoir cette émission en
replay rendez vous sur le site internet
ou sur l'application mobile télé 78 vous
retrouverez l'information lundi dans le
7-8 journal présenté par grégory canal
et mercy est passé un excellent week end
[Musique]